si monsieur le président c'est pas si
c'est une belle défense et pour partie
un réquisitoire
à mon endroit alors je vais d'abord
présenté au sénat toutes mes excuses
j'ai d'abord présenté je vais d'abord
j'avais prévenu le sénat d'ailleurs
n'est pas anormal que le garde des
sceaux et était aux côtés du président
de la république
pour l' annonce des états généraux de la
justice d'ailleurs il y avait à mes
côtés madame guigou madame la ministre
guigou et je sais que
[Musique]
l'une d'entre vous a évoqué hier une
campagne électorale
on pas que madame la ministre guigou
fasse campagne pour le président de la
république qui au demeurant n'est pas
candidat il y avait également monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
du sénat qui était à mes côtés madame v
rien également j'ai la faiblesse de
penser qu'ils ne viennent pas non plus
faire la campagne électorale du
président de la république qui je le
rappelle à cet instant n'est pas
candidat il y avait également un certain
nombre d'autres parlementaires je vais
vous dire dans quel état on se retrouve
monsieur le sénateur et vous allez
comprendre si le président de la
république ne travaille plus on dit il
est en campagne si le travail jusqu'au
dernier quart d'heure on dit aussi il
est en campagne alors oui et c'est
compliqué de son sortir ces états
généraux de la justice c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement important
dans un premier temps nous avons
souhaité restaurer la justice avec un
budget exceptionnel mettre en oeuvre un
certain nombre de mesures vous les
connaissez l ont été notamment débattu
ici et dans un deuxième temps il est
question de moderniser la justice nous
avons choisi le futuroscope je lui ai
déjà dit et non pas les grottes de
lascaux pas ce que nous envisageons bien
sûr la justice du futur alors hier
madame la sénatrice de la gontrie vous
avez cru devoir dire que j'étais en
campagne aux côtés du président de la
république et vous il ya quelques jours
il ya quelques jours je vous ai vu aux
côtés de madame hidalgo juste derrière
elle vous étiez sainte toutes les deux
de vos écharpes tricolores vous
annonciez je crois la police municipale
moi je n'ai pas pensé une seconde je
n'ai pas pensé une seconde mais pour ce
sujet ou pour un autre laissez-moi
terminé je n'ai pas pensé une seconde
que vous étiez en campagne pas du tout
j'ai pensé que vous étiez là pour
défendre votre territoire d'ailleurs si
vous aviez été en campagne et ses côtés
ne serait plus à 4% voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire tout ça ce sont des
polémiques stériles je vais enfin
répondre mais pas du tout je vous ai
expliqué qu'il est bien normal que le
garde des sceaux souhaite aux côtés du
président de la république pour les
états généraux de la justice et je suis
ravi de voir que j'ai pu vous manqué et
je veux préciser ici à la représentation
nationale mais elle le sait que les
articles que je porte nous allons
seulement commencé à les évoquer dans
quelques secondes et vous l'avez fait
d'ailleurs monsieur le sénateur sûr
[Musique]